to co-parent is a different beast it's
probably the hardest thing I've ever had
to figure out co-parenting is hella hard
and Chloe is feeling it big-time
I just kind of been avoiding having this
conversation in a sneak peak at keeping
up with the kardashians cocoa turns to
her mom Kris Jenner for advice since her
ex Tristan Thompson was back in
Cleveland Ohio for the new NBA season at
a serious question to ask you oh god
what to co-parent is a different beast
it's probably the hardest thing I've
ever had to figure out because you get
territorial like this is my baby what do
you do telling me what today Matt yeah
like you forget oh no it's both your
baby the two split in February 20 19 min
his cheating scandal with Kylie Jenner's
former bestie Jordan Woods you know
things happen and of course I'm sorry
and apologetic as much as I can be it's
the first basketball season that Chloe
won't be in Ohio with Tristan and she's
not sure what that means for splitting
up time with their two-year-old daughter
true Tristan is back in Cleveland the
NBA season is starting this is the first
season that I am not with Tristan
typically I go back and forth about
every other week to Cleveland he really
misses true and he doesn't really know
when he's gonna see her next and I
really have not put much thought into
how true is going to visit Tristan in
Cleveland I just kind of been avoiding
having this conversation and while
there's a lot that's up in the air
there's one thing Chloe knows for sure
she wants to keep it friendly honestly
and truthfully I just want us to have a
peaceful friendship and just distance
yeah Tristan's been really consistent
and present and that's great but I just
like haven't even thought of this part
yet yeah this part being the logistics
does that mean I have to send true there
by herself
co-parenting is hard and you have to
also like respect both parents
yeah but I'm like I don't know I don't
know what I feel comfortable that I'm
sure you won't make me do anything I
don't feel comfortable doing but then is
that even fair for true to not see her
dad because that's gonna be a long
however many months that's when Chloe
admits she's pretty jelly of her sister
Courtney and her setup with her ex Scott
Disick when it comes to raising their
three kids
Kourtney and Scott at least they're two
miles from each other I know when Scott
wants to see the kids or if Mason wants
to go spend the night with dad he just
goes over there it's not like they just
gives me anxiety to think I would have
to send her anywhere like she's just a
baby
you'll figure it out when et caught up
with Scott in 2019 he opened up about
the secret sauce to co-parenting like a
boss I think you just gotta figure out
really what's important to you at the
end of the day I mean you just want to
be happy you want to be content you want
to be comfortable life is a challenge
and if you work at what you want you can
get it but it takes hard work simple as
that you can easily live less of a life
without working as hard and Chloe gave
Kourt Scott and Scott's girlfriend
Sophia Richey mad props it's hard work
for all parties I think 400 in court
Sophia they're all really it's I'm
really proud of all of them yeah I got
it I mean Courtney being your older
sister do you guys do you look to them
and kind of learn from what you know
Kourtney and Scott are doing I think
they're doing amazing and I think
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but my mom and my dad were like
that it took them years but my dad would
come over once a week for family dinners
and would play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you shared children
with people and that's how it should be
and love is love and I'm so proud of
them and I'm so proud of them promoting
that and hopefully you know inspiring
other people that it's a beautiful thing
to get along with each other and for
your kids to see that Chloe and Tristan
seem to be crushing it - in December the
reality star hit up Twitter to update
fans on the status of her relationship
with the NBA star writing quote we are
co-parenting so well right now
is a great space to be in co-parenting
is such a hard space much respect to all
co-parent errs and went et sat down with
her in October she said for now she's
just focusing on her baby girl I'm just
super happy and content and I'm focused
on work and like taking care of me my
body and soul and true
[Music]